ach ja wer kennt es nicht das tolle neue
oder etwas ältere iphone und android und
blackberry spiel 2048 oder auf englisch
2000 forty eight wo ganz einfach das
ziel des spiels ist dass man wenn man
beispielsweise eine 202 hat zieht man
diese beiden nummern zusammen bekommt
eine vier aus vier und vier werden 8 16
32 und immer verdoppelt bis zu 2048 x
2048 erreicht ist das spiel vorbei es
macht sehr sehr süchtig deswegen lade
deutsches besser nicht runter allerdings
möchte ich euch das spiel zeigen sondern
davon einem eine variante in minecraft
ist bekomme ich hier schon so
sprachstörungen ein youtube eine
variante dazu hergestellt in minecraft
ich verlinke euch das alles unten drin
wo ihr euch das runterladen könnt das
spiel erklärt sich von selbst und damit
erst mal hallo zu der vorstellung hier
ich hoffe euch geht's gut wir brauchen
dafür den lakers snapshot und ich kann
mal f1 drücken und wenn ihr in die web
rein kommt erstmal das tier steht vor
dieser wand wahrscheinlich bauen sich
die nummern dann geradeaus und auf und
die textur ist dann so ein bisschen
schwammig dass verbessert sich aber noch
ein paar sekunden
ich lese das erstmal vor wie nahmen wir
sind gerd tausendfreund ein teil der ec
bürger egal
how to play use this way to move it went
to the same name touch the world tour
und presste restart und ich hab den
erfolg will dass ich wohl mein inventar
geöffnet ab das ist ja gut ich würde
sagen die regeln stehen fest wir müssen
das ganze mit der spd bewegen und space
drücken und zu starten deswegen habe ich
das jetzt mal angefangen so sieht unser
anfangs rhinos wir haben hier eine 4
ich probiere jetzt mal ich drücke jetzt
mal wbc nach vorne und jetzt sind die
ganzen nummern die ich hatte nach oben
gehören
wer jetzt nach rechts drücke müssten
alle nummern nach rechts gehen also die
vier es dann oben rechts die zwei oben
rechts die zweite zahl und dann halt
kommt jetzt gerade nochmal eine 21
stimmt alles sich die männer nach oben
paare diese beiden jetzt hab ich eine 4
und 40 zurück weil es nach rechts ich
habe eine acht auf der rechten seite
jetzt hab ich da eine zwei und zwei
darunter noch eine 2 jetzt nach oben
drücken
münchen die beiden zu einer 4 jetzt
drücke ich mal nach links weil jetzt
habe ich 4 84 28 16 04 das klappt schon
mal alles supergut ich hole das erstmal
rechts alles
sag jetzt wieder 24 sogar 34
jetzt habe ich eine 6 16 und 18
jetzt muss ich halt irgendwie 8 zu auch
zu einer recht zu bekommen und dann die
beiden 16 irgendwie zusammen machen das
bekomme ich so so und so und jetzt habe
ich eine 32 schon etwas für ihre zahl so
dass auch schöner ich konnte jetzt die
beiden oberen abbauen
also es macht echt süchtig auch wenn ihr
irgendwie kein handy habt mittlerweile
hat jeder handynutzer egal wenn ihr da
irgendwie drauf habt auf dieses spiel
dann spielt ist auf jeden fall minecraft
1964 das macht auf jeden fall richtig
süchtig dieses spiel
es ist egal ob ihr das offen handy
spielt oder in minecraft das ist
eigentlich hat den gleichen effekt also
man wird süchtig man man will einfach
immer höher kommen bei mir was damals
auf dem handy so was gab's ein spiel das
sie es irgendwie ferries also ths damit
zwei ich weiß gar nicht also free wird
nur zwei geschrieben aber diese app war
halt relativ genau so aufgebaut
ich weiß nicht welcher ein kopierer war
welche ich finde 2048 auf jeden fall
minimalistisch gehalten und ich liebe
minimalistische apps sind auch die
einzigen die spieler ich möchte nicht so
was mit nachricht kraft in grafik
sondern mehr was mit richtig spiel spaß
und so was gefällt mir dass sich die
schöne aus gold spiele die halt richtig
spannend sind auch wenn man sich mal
ganz kurz verpflegt und amec scheiße
weil einer nach unten wenn man so ein
bisschen druck macht das nix man muss
schon ganz nach hinten laufen so guck
mal ich habe hier die nächste 64 grad am
start
ich hoffe ich das jetzt so hin wie ich
mir das vorgestellt habe so moment hier
noch eine hier noch eine da so also wenn
ich jetzt wie ich spiele diesmal nur
eine runde weil ich nicht möchte dass
das video hier über zehn minuten lang
und ihr könnt mir video antworten geht
überhaupt noch gibt es das video einfach
die weiße haus bei youtube mal etwas
längeren pause jetzt ich kann zum
beispiel nicht nach rechts mal nach
rechts nicht verschoben werden kann
aber nach links eine menge so ich möchte
doch nur die beiden 64 jahren
miteinander verbinden mensch ich glaube
dass wir gar nichts mehr ich gar nix
mehr geschossen gerade so die beiden
komiker sound so als ob ich jetzt jetzt
noch hier die beiden führen da sind
schöner 16 32 42 32 leute ist die 3 2 1
läuft hier habe die erste 128 kann das
übrigens hier auch wenn damit dass er
ein bisschen schön aussieht 128 man kann
auch das svw einstellen das ganze so
machen dass sie dann natürlich
selbstverständlich noch schöner aus ich
mach das mal so dass es so ein bisschen
noch zu erkennen ist ja finde ich sehr
schön
also es ist super geil gemacht das muss
man echt sagen fallen wenn man das so
sieht
ich werde mir auf jeden fall ins netz
schob mir dieser welt drin lassen weil
ich finde dass das ganze
ich hätte mich in den charakter von
liebe ich finde das ist ganz schön
übrigens wie findet ihr das wenn ich
lasst einfach mal daumen hoch da wenn
ihr wollt dass ich öfters solche sachen
forscht eine solche coolen spiele wo ihr
euch auch so denken können so mensch
dann ist nicht so cool weil der luca das
macht so wie bei wow oder dachtet ihr
euch ja ich will auch dabei sein und so
bin ich hier geht's halt ich spiel das
ihr könnt euch runterladen und ihr könnt
auch spielen das ist der unterschied
findet ihr das cool oder sagte er
macht man lieber so projekte scheiße 256
ps der profi vor 650 bei 28 40 geschafft
seiner spitze es ist klasse ich habe
übrigens gerade ein zug schon mal
weitermacht jetzt bin ich hier so gerade
das sind das geht immer schneller also
mit der zeit man selbst hat natürlich
den besten überblick
denkt euch jetzt immer so hell wie kann
er das so schnell sehen ich gucke
natürlich waren das hier zuschauer
hinguckt ihr macht das dann
wahrscheinlich ganz anders wenn ihr das
ganze gespielt wie gesagt ihr könnt euch
runter laden steht alles in der
beschreibung gar kein ding kann das
ganze ein bisschen schneller machen dass
wir das hier so alles sehen so ein
bisschen hier alles wenn man kann man
auch machen möchte das aber natürlich
jeder vor fact die beiden fielen da oben
kann man nicht so gut zu kommentieren
aber ist wirklich super ich kann sich
ich sage das so oft das hier ist das
unterlassen bekommt nichts dafür dass
ihr euch das und wenn ihr euch das
runterladen
red aber ich find's einfach klasse und
ich finde solche ideen müssten gerade
supported werden in einer minecraft
szene in der ist teilweise echt an
kreativität fehlt also finde ich echt
spitze und irgendwie nimmt das bei mir
auch gerade kein ende
was mich ein wenig verwirrt weil ich
dachte eigentlich soja höchste zahl 128
aber schon nur 256 das ist ja es ist ja
klasse mensch das ist ja unglaublich
es könne trotzdem jetzt viel langsamer
ich muss auch noch leben würden anderes
aufnehmen
also wie gesagt morgen kommen noch eine
andere game app ich auch ganz cool wie
sie teils noch besser als das hier
möchte jetzt aber nichts verraten hier
so ich denke aber dass das findet gleich
auch sein ende weil da oben kann sich
nahezu gleich zwei panther in 32 stehen
natürlich durfte das muss einfach sagen
das habe ich scheiße ausgetüftelt sind
32 hinten als kriterium zur seite
schieben so kommt die acht hierhin so
oder so ein starker zug
und ich möchte jetzt beide 16 am
liebsten mal eben paar stark jetzt habe
ich da die 32 332 stimmt wie wärs wenn
ich das einfach mal nach unten ziehe
luca mensch ich kriege immer wieder 2
256 alleine da werden
ich habe 2 256 und ich weiß alle in den
kommentaren hat schon zehn millionen
meine freunde das glaub ich mein bestes
spiel was bisher gemacht habe ich habe
alles auf kamera also ich weiss ich
spiele das ganze jetzt mal ein bisschen
vor und zeigt euch danach der mine and
screen damit das hier nicht so lange
dauert
freunde sind mir bei dem punkt
angekommen ich laufe nach hinten nichts
passiert doch nach links nichts passiert
nach rechts vor links und nach vorne
passiert nichts
sap wurde jetzt durchgangs geschrieben
doch aebischer kam die nachricht ich
hatte f1 modus es ist jetzt vorbei ihr
könnt jetzt mal meine höchstpunktzahl
irgendwie hier zusammen zählen von
meinen ganzen punkten und schauen ob ihr
darüber kommt schreibt beim europa
league kommentar ich will nicht so was
sehen wie zehn millionen 33 oder so
schreibt es in den kommentaren leute
durch die map lasten bewertung da wenn
euch solche videos gefallen schaffen wir
2000 daumen hoch
erich keller und was würde ich sagen
euch noch ein wunderschönen tag und
schau